the effervescent Dan Polly sack of MLB
Network joining us right here again re
around the Rich Eisen show how are you
Dan rich I'm good I love it Chicago mold
you I laugh only this could only mean
the world of pro sports right like your
team stay in the best hotels in the
world it's not like guys are staying it
like there's some rope motor in
somewhere on the south side of Chicago
right I mean they're probably staying at
the Westin right on Michigan Avenue so I
don't know you know rich it's hard to
put a finger on what's going what the
hell is going on with the Nationalists
you would assumed I was listening to the
lead-in they get the extra day you would
assume Strasbourg's going today I mean
come on what what the hell's going on
there I mean and this is I think part in
lies in what's wrong why they can't win
two playoff series three years ago he
couldn't pitch I you know I don't know
in his town right that was the a nice
town here what up or shut up time right
I mean listen we've heard this it's this
time of the year right now their backs
are up against the wall they're down two
games to one
it's his normal days rest yesterday they
said he might be available on the
bullpen but he threw a bullpen and then
they weren't sure if he threw a bullpen
or not come on what what I mean it
enough already
either either take the ball and listen
we don't need any built-in excuses if he
pitches poorly today it was because he
had the sniffles or he had a mold issue
let's go
come on you know what I mean it's time
to man up and go and and I was hoping
this was going to be the postseason 2017
that we could put all that to bed with
Stephen Strasburg because I'm a huge fan
of his rich listen from a talent
standpoint and what he able to do the
last eight ten starts at the regular
season he was as good as any pitcher in
baseball and I thought in Game one he
pitched he pitched long he should have
won that game ten strikeouts seven
innings two unearned runs he picks great
and I thought this would be the
postseason rich that we could stop the
excuses is he made out of paper does if
you don't I mean and listen I did take
the ball today and I really want him to
go out there and throw the ball well
today if he does [ __ ] we still don't
know yet what's gonna happen
Walker Strasburg it sounds like it's
Strasburg from everything that I'm
reading on Twitter right now so is so is
there a pitch count I've ever heard of a
pitcher having a pitch time not a spores
count as their scores count we check
we're counting spores as well Danny I
know you know what you know what and
that that's you know what rich and
that's why listen we can't root for any
particular team I have some teams that I
root for I have some players that are
root for but that's why I'm rooting for
CC Sabathia tonight for the Yankees you
know what it is listen he's listen he is
not the guy that he was seven eight
years ago he single-handedly carried the
Milwaukee Brewers to the postseason
right hood he wanted star young but you
know what he does he takes the ball
every five days no complaining no crying
if there's anybody that has a built-in
excuse he's had a bad knee a bump back
you know he's had some elbow and
shoulder issues but you know what I can
tell you this I don't know if the
Yankees are gonna win tonight but I
don't think there's a picture I'd rather
have going into this game that I could
trust to get through five or six innings
like CC Sabathia hitting and I know I'm
not supposed to root for teams or guys
but I'm gonna make it known I root for
CC Sabathia he's my kind of guy okay
okay now I'm I'm part of that Yankee fan
of Dan that's sitting here thinking when
Joe Girardi said after they won Game
four my guys picked me up and I'm
sitting there thinking Girardi will not
have been picked up by his guys until
they move on in the series because they
should already be there
you're you and I must think the same way
because you know what we yes because we
were just in a meeting to pre-show
meeting for the three o'clock I'm gonna
be under 3:00 to 4:30 Eastern pregame to
this cub game on MLB Network yeah and
all of our research guys are all Yankee
fans right and they said the same thing
that you said and I thought he will be
forgiving if they win this game five and
move on if they lose this game five a
lot of Yankee fans right now in this
building here at MLB Network they're re
we should won this series already it
should be over already and I agree with
you I think he'll get a pick me up if
they went tonight all will be forgiven
and then they'll move on I agree with
you well but you know researchers and
then guys like me sitting here and
and having been around clubhouses though
it's not you've been in dugouts and
things move fast things are crazy they
do I understand what have you determined
for real what in the hell happened that
dugout that Friday night no you know
this is the only thing I can I can tell
you that I know is if we've seen
managers and what they do they're always
looking for their bench coats or that
guy that's you know in contact upstairs
what the guys are on camera and this is
the problem rich is there are a lot of
different reviews and angles that are
used but the last one that was used in
that game was the most clear one that
showed that it hit off the knob of the
bat the problem is that was about fifty
seconds in you have about thirty Seconds
to challenge so I think what happened
was Joe was kind of sitting there
looking for help from somebody in the
clubhouse or in their replay senator
that saying yeah go ahead and challenge
it
there wasn't an angle that was shown
enough in time for them to see that it
hit the bottom of the bat and I think
and that's end up getting he got left by
the side of the curb because of that and
instead of then he came up with the he
didn't want to disrupt the flow of the
game which you know he makes a pitch
trips out to get pitchers and Mary
Sanchez every other pitch is running out
so I didn't buy any of that either he he
simply got caught with his pants down
and he admitted to it I'll give him this
the next day he admitted to it the next
day he should have challenged it because
again Dan and just and then we'll put a
button on it move on to a couple other
things with Dan police act named BB
network that you know as I said it the
other day too and I'll repeat it to you
no better way to keep your pitcher in
rhythm than the by putting his ass on
the bench out of the inning
there's no that's it you want to keep
your pitcher and rhythm get him out of
the inning thank you end a story of the
teams that are sitting at home right now
rootin for 20 inning games tonight and
in the case of the Dodgers a fifth game
Dodgers and Astros let's just assume
maybe they advanced which one's the
better team Dan what do you like you
know I was down on the Dodgers because
of what I saw the last like three and a
half to four weeks but with that said
rich they they swept a pretty good
Diamondbacks team and not a pretty good
a real good they made a good team look
bad and the Diamondbacks were playing
some pretty good baseball what that said
I was really disappointed in ball
starts by zack greinke i expected more
out of Greggy and I thought what we saw
out of the Dodgers in that series what
we saw when they were on that historic
run a lot of depth some quality at-bats
yasiel Puig starting to play like a
really good player Bellinger starting to
wake up Seager starting to wake up there
are they're a really good team I don't
think they're a great team they're a
good team I'm not completely sold on
their starting pitching their bullpen
looks really good right now with that
said I think the Astros right now might
be the best team in the a land I going
in I thought it was the Cleveland
Indians but after watching this euston
Astros team that's not a team I want to
mess with that lineup is really deep
Springer swinging a bat well Correa
swinging about really well Reddick came
up with some big hits burr Lander has
been a game changer yes I'm a little
concerned about the back end of their
bullpen III listen I feel like I told
you two weeks ago when we talked I think
if the Yankees can get out of this game
five the Yankees could very easily find
themselves in the World Series the
Yankees are a really good team they are
they are a really good team and and they
may have found something with this Cain
Lee guy coming out of the bullpen but
Tangis I think you could forget about
him in Game five after what we saw in
Game four rich forget about but dances
like Paulie and the Godfather you want
some you won't see him no more
kailia stepped up I like this I for some
reason I know this is unconventional
thinking but for some reason I think
somehow some way the Yankees pull out
this game 5-2 I do and if they do I
think they're gonna get to the World
Series I really I like the Yankees in a
in a seven-game series against the
Houston Astros I think the Yankees could
beat them in seven honey I dad so let me
just move on one last thing here do you
agree or disagree with the dismissal of
John Farrell in Boston today I I kind of
agree with it I think there was some
there was some concern that was going
through that clubhouse you know where
there's smoke there's fire
and and I think for the most part every
manager there's an expiration date with
certain organizations and it's hard to
say that when you've won back-to-back
titles but I I think it was time for him
to move on endless and
he wasn't a Dave Dombrowski guy he he
inherited him when he took over baseball
operations so and the way that thing
goes in front office's now the guys had
to run it they want their own people
running the ship underneath so I think
this was just a matter of time it was
gonna so who's that guy he's gonna call
Jim Leyland see if he's got one more
yeah but Jim I play golf with Jim
Leyland like four weeks ago yeah here in
New York yeah and he says he's done
managing he doesn't want to do it again
and I believed them this time okay I
think he enjoys being retired there's no
way you'll see Jim Leyland and Doug out
there's a good question I don't know who
that means there's speculation he may
bring in Brad Ausmus we had a Detroit
now I don't know Brad Ausmus his name is
popping up a lot now Sandy Alderson a
Dartmouth guy the Mets job is open
offices being the Dartmouth grad the
Phillies job their GM is a Dartmouth guy
so red officers the kind of link to like
three or four different places right now
well I mean I mean in Boston Dartmouth
is like 10th on the list there man I
mean got Harvard you know I thought I
thought Jason Varitek name is an
intriguing name he kind of always hear
his name being thrown around so maybe
that could be a guy you know I know
whoever it is better be a thick-skinned
guy because that's a tough job to take
it is Dan thanks for joining appreciate
it look forward to seeing you on MLB
Network what you said 3:00 Eastern Time
curry MLB tonight airs before and after
every single postseason game visit MLB
network.com for your local channel
listings take care Dan you got a damn
see sack the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint